bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions sur arte france sept partis
pour gouverner comment décider à 7 c'est
beaucoup donc bonjour alors
effectivement c'est inédit même cette
partie blindée réussissent avec le
gouvernement di rupo en ascète ici c'est
beaucoup pour en termes de contenu mais
aussi et on le voit encore
particulièrement aujourd'hui en terre le
casting pour la question des postes
ministériels à répartir le libéral
flamand alexander de croo on le sait ce
sera donc le nouveau premier ministre on
sait son rival paul magnette qui l'a
annoncé tout à l'heure
quel est son profil et quelle sera sa
politique alors un profil avec une
certaine expérience je dirais il a
présidé le parti libéral open vld
pendant tout un temps il est devenu
propre vice premier ministre a occupé
différentes fonctions ministérielles au
niveau fédéral ces dernières années et
est parfaitement bilingue
en belgique c'est un élément qui peut
être particulièrement important se
souvient d'elio di rupo qui en 2011 2
les premiers ministres et qui avait été
pas mal pointé du doigt justement pour
ça son manque de connaissance de la
langue néerlandaise à quel gouvernement
il faudra s'attendre maintenant c'est
place à jean biart des tractations
politico-politicienne non pour répartir
les différents portefeuilles
là c'est ce qui est en cours depuis
depuis ce matin on se demander d'abord
qui serait le premier ministre
maintenant que ce poste a été distribué
je dirais qu'elles sont de distribuer
les autres postes au sein de ce
gouvernement
tous les postes n'ont pas le même poids
le poste de la santé par exemple est
sans doute particulièrement important
durant cette législature notamment en
termes budgétaires comme le laisse à
penser l'accord de gouvernement et
particulièrement dans ce contexte de
crise sanitaire que nous connaissons et
que nous connaître
vraisemblablement dans les prochains
mois et en tout cas les conséquences
pendant encore quelques années on va
justement à côté de vous à ce fil will
messe à l'ancienne première ministre
donc de la belgique
pourtant si je ne m'abuse son bilan a
été plutôt bon pour la crise sanitaire 3
n'est plus là ça c'est jeudi une
spécificité aussi du système politique
belge nous avions ici un gouvernement
minoritaire qui réunit ces trois partis
politiques autour de la table qui
avaient été mises en place sur mois de
mars en vue de répondre à la crise
politique et particulièrement de
répondre à la crise sanitaire travers
l'instauration de ce gouvernement de
plein exercice pour rappel ça fait quand
même six cent cinquante jours
aujourd'hui que nous n'avions plus de
gouvernement majoritaire
en belgique il n'était plus de plein
exercice jusqu'au mois de mars
et donc il y avait une volonté pour ce
film est de diriger un gouvernement pour
lequel elle re demanderai la confiance
au moins de septembre mais il était
attendu
effectivement qu'une comme d'autres
partis politiques je dirais rejoindrez
le bateau est donc c'est sur la base de
nouveaux d'un nouvel accord que ce
gouvernement succède à celui de ce film
s verquin le chemin va se diriger la
belgique avec avec tout ça ce que la
belgique sera plus tournées vers
l'environnement ces cas les écologistes
qui font leur retour l'ours comme vous
le disiez il il ya sept partis autour de
la table chaque partie ait essayé je
dirais de gagner un trophée en plusieurs
trophées bien entendu bien entendu
tir environnementale avec la question de
la sortie du nucléaire qui est programmé
pour 2025 avec certaines conditions
comme le laisse comme le suggère un
accord de gouvernement donc c'est un
trophée effectivement pour les
écologistes en matière de santé en
matière d'augmentation de la pension net
à 1520 on peut dire que c'est plutôt un
trophée pour les socialistes
d'autres questions par exemple en
matière institutionnelle sont davantage
à trophées pour les sociaux chrétiens
flamands du cd donc chacun a pu je
dirais tirer son épingle du jeu dans cet
accord de gouvernement nous verrons
maintenant dans les prochaines années
comment cet accord de gouvernement se
traduit en décisions publiques concret
et quel sera l'effet de ces de ses
décisions pour les citoyens le projet
d'accord doit encore être validé par
chacun des partis si je ne m'abuse
qu'est ce qui peut se passer ce que le
projet d'accord peut quand même devenir
caduque est-ce que le gouvernement va
vraiment avoir être nommé demain on
s'est tu doit prêter serment demain
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir des freins à
tous à ce que cette coalition de sept
partis différents est ce que ça peut
handicaper la gouvernance du pays
alors ça nécessite effectivement que
chacun des partis ratifie à sa base
directement l'accord de gouvernement où
chaque partie ce soir à organiser un
congrès de participation comme on les
appelle et qui vont valider d'une
certaine manière cet accord de
gouvernement classiquement c'est quelque
chose qui se passe assez bien l'accord
de gouvernement et généralement ratifié
par les différents partis politiques
avec une exception je dirais quand même
hein ce sont les écologistes les
écologistes qui font qu'ils amènent
leurs bases leur au mitan se prononcer
non seulement sur le fond sur la
participation des écologistes à à
l'égard de l'accord de gouvernement qui
est dégagé mais aussi sur les personnes
au sein de leur parti qui rejoindront le
gouvernement il en a déjà vu typiquement
en 1999 typiquement l'an dernier
également que les militants pour avoir
un poids particulièrement important pour
recaler une personnalité de leur propre
formation politique est bon plus tôt
vendre d'envisager une autre nommer une
autre finalement une responsabilité que
je sois ministériel ou au niveau d'un
secrétariat d'état
merci benjamin brouillard d'avoir
répondu à des questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chargé de recherche au crisp
le centre de recherche et d'information
socio politique